este problema nos dice racionalista y
simplifica 16 más 2 x al cuadrado entre
raíz de 8 y como suele suceder en
matemáticas hay varias formas de
resolver este problema podríamos
simplificar un poquito después
racionalizar y luego simplificar un poco
más o bien racionalizar de entrada y
después simplificar vamos a hacerlo de
las dos formas pero antes para que
estemos en el mismo canal déjame decirte
que racionalizar quiere decir que no
queremos que aparezcan raíces cuadradas
en el denominado vale bueno entonces voy
a hacer la primera solución donde
primero simplificó un poco y para hacer
esta simplificación voy a utilizar que
raíz de 8 es igual a raíz de 4 por 2 y
utilizando propiedades de los radicales
esto es igual a raíz de 4 por raíz de 2
de modo que la expresión nos queda igual
a 16 más 2x al cuadrado dividido entre
raíz de 4 que es 2 x raíz de 2 y observa
ahora el numerador y el denominador son
divisibles entre 2 tenemos 16
y dos así que podemos dividir entre dos
arriba y abajo y aquí nos queda 8 16
entre 28 aquí nos queda 12 entre 2 es
uno y aquí 2 entre 2 también nos queda
uno bueno déjame reescribir esta
expresión aquí abajo entonces la
expresión original es igual a 88 más x
al cuadrado dividido entre raíz de 2 va
entonces ahora sí tenemos que
racionalizar hay que desaparecer este
raíz de 2 del denominador y para eso
vamos a multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por raíz de 2 es decir vamos
a multiplicar arriba por raíz de 2 y
abajo también que nos queda si hacemos
esto bueno pues nos queda 8 x raíz de 28
por raíz de 2 + raíz de 2 por equis
cuadrada raíz de 2 por equis cuadrada y
eso dividido entre raíz de dos por raíz
de 2 que es igual a 2 vale bueno y esto
de aquí ya que es igual aquí tengo
podríamos dejarlo así esto ya se ve
suficientemente simplificado pero
partiendo la fracción
sumandos nos queda 8 entre 2 raíz de 2 o
sea 4 raíz de 2 4 raíz de 2 + raíz de 2
entre 2 entre 2 por x al cuadrado bueno
cualquiera de estas dos expresiones es
válida ya depende de tu gusto decir cuál
de éstas está más simplificada pero
bueno te decía que hay otra forma de
resolver este problema que consiste en
racionalizar de entrada vamos a hacer
eso con color azul entonces voy a copiar
aquí la expresión 16 + 2 x al cuadrado
dividido entre raíz de 8 entre raíz de 8
y lo que vamos a hacer es multiplicar el
numerador y el denominador por raíz de 8
entonces aquí sería x raíz de 8 entre
raíz de 8 vamos a ver que nos queda a
ver 16 x raíz de 8 es 16 raíz de 8 16
raíz de 8 ya eso tenemos que sumar 2
raíz de 8 por equis cuadrada 2 raíz de 8
por equis cuadrada y en el denominador
nos queda raíz de 8 por raíz de 8 que es
igual a 8
una vez más el numerador y el
denominador son ambos divisibles entre 2
entonces podemos simplificar un poco
este 16 se puede hacer 18 este 8 un 4 y
éste 2 1 1 y entonces esto nos queda
igual a déjame déjame copiarlo con otro
color es igual a 8 raíz de 8 más este ya
si son 1 entonces es raíz de 8 x al
cuadrado dividido entre 4 y bueno en
realidad está ahí está todavía no se
parecen pero lo que sucede es que aún no
hemos simplificado este raíz de 8 vale
entonces si lo simplificamos poniéndolo
así como 2 raíz de dos aquí nos quedaría
2 por raíz de dos y nos quedaría 2 por
raíz de 2 raíz de 2
una vez más el numerador y el
denominador son divisibles entre 2
entonces este 2 lo podemos cancelar este
donde podemos cancelar y este 4 se hace
2 de modo que nos queda 8 por raíz de 2
lo voy a poner en
naranja nos queda 8 x raíz de dos más
raíz de 2 x x al cuadrado raíz de 2 x x
al cuadrado y el denominador se
simplificó a 2 entonces después de hacer
todas las simplificaciones vemos que
esta expresión y esta de acá esta de acá
son iguales vale entonces obtenemos la
misma respuesta